this video is brought to you by bright
sellers
[Music]
what's up guys michael here and today
i'm going to post up in the philosophy
section of the south park library and
see what sort of wisdom and truths our
buds matt and trey have for us in the
show's 25th season now south park's been
critiquing various elements of american
politics and culture since i was in
middle school in fact the best gift i
got for my 14th birthday was the
original motion picture soundtrack to
south park bigger longer uncut
coincidentally that was also the first
movie i ever got caught sneaking into
oops but this season the show's
skepticism seems more focused the first
few episodes all explore aspects of our
culture that can best be understood
through the lens of an ideology called
neo-liberalism the show's cultural jabs
all point to the way that this political
and economic ideology takes things like
public controversy social movements and
economic opportunities and renders them
meaningless in the name of profit so
what happens when we analyze some
cartoon kids who have an age in a
quarter century alongside some
philosophers who are super duper dead
let's find out in this philosopher
reacts to south park season 25
so far and spoilers ahead for the first
three episodes of season 25 of south
park
but before we get into it i want to tell
you about this video's sponsored bright
sellers bright sellers is a subscription
wine service that helps you discover new
wines that you'll definitely love and
because they curate exclusive brands
plus wines from small vineyards from all
over the world chances are they'll
introduce you to wines you otherwise
never would have had an opportunity to
try now the process starts with a seven
question quiz which feeds into a
sophisticated algorithm to figure out
your taste profile for instance i told
bright sellers that i like coffee i'm
not really into sweets and i generally
prefer reds and so my first box they
sent me wines like this merlot which has
notes of vanilla a little bit of a oak
and plum flavor to it and as you can see
a very cool label
and this
garutsiminer which is a white that i
never would have tried before but i
really like now i'm a bit of a wine guy
myself but there's still a lot i don't
know and brightseller's emphasis on wine
education can help me keep learning now
every bottle comes with its own wine
education card which includes tasting
notes recommended pairings and other fun
facts right cellars is the most
convenient way to try new wines since
they're delivered right to your door and
it's also a sustainable practice the
packaging is recyclable and plastic free
plus your monthly bottles may include
biodynamic and sustainable varietals
also bright cellars has some cool new
offerings this month including low
alcohol varietals and sparkling wines so
you can snag the perfect bottle for any
occasion get fifty percent off your
first six bottle box at
brightsellers.com wisecrack4 that's
brightsellers.com
wisecrack and the number four for a
total of only fifty five dollars
including shipping bright sellers is the
monthly wine club that matches you with
the wine you'll love get started by
taking the taste palette quiz to see
your personalized matches and now
back to the show let's start with the
first episode of the season in which the
kids understandably just really want to
wear pajamas to school but this being
south park in 2022 matt and trey also
found some time to rag on celebrity love
for decentralized currency let's check
out our first clip bruh we can have some
goddamn balls what does matt damon say
on that bitcoin commercial fortune
favors the brave my dad said he listened
to matt damon and lost all his buddy yes
everyone did okay so it's worth quickly
noting the continuity between this nod
to celebrity crypto endorsements and the
nft plot line in the south park post
coveted special which we previously
covered it's a nice hint of things to
come as it's clear that for matt and
trey the hype around crypto simply
represents one facet of the utter
emptiness at the heart of our culture
and okay until a crypto bro comes
knocking at my door with an exciting
spiritual opportunity crypto isn't
technically a religion but it does make
me think of marx's infamous assertion
that religion is the opiate of the
masses this line is up there with
nietzsche's god is dead in the hall of
fame of philosophical statements that
are oft-quoted and rarely understood and
that's because people they always ignore
the words that immediately precede
uh marx's assertion that religion is the
name of a new pill produced by the
sackler family because the sacklers are
bad people that make opiates that are
ruining our country those words are
religion is the sigh of the oppressed
creature the heart of a heartless world
and the soul of soulless conditions
meaning that marx isn't some religion
hating edge
instead he's pointing out that when
people's lives and social conditions
suck ass they look for meaning and
purpose somewhere else and this is a
theme throughout these episodes folks
trying to find meaning and purpose in
their otherwise meaningless lives except
they don't do it through religion
they do it in much dumber ways hey guys
i just want to say i'm really proud to
be a part of this office
wearing our pajamas shows that we care
about those school kids
that we care about other people south
park realtors
south park realtors okay so this idea
that wearing pajamas
shows that you care about kids or more
generally um that wearing or purchasing
a certain product signifies you showing
solidarity with a marginalized group
is an empty gesture at best and it shows
how our soulish condition is no longer
centered around religion but some mix of
marketing and capitalism maybe it used
to be important to define yourself via a
religious affiliation i.e
as a good catholic i would never have
pre-marital sex
during lent or on christmas but these
days it's more about defining ourselves
via our consumer habits
i wear pajamas to stand with the
children or i eat at ihop because they
only serve pajama people i'm sorry sir
but we aren't seating anyone who isn't
wearing their pajamas and this
transition from religion to capitalism
or more accurately capitalism becoming
the dominant system of belief has turned
lots of social and political issues into
matters of consumption
as walter benjamin wrote in the aptly
titled capitalism as religion a religion
may be discerned in capitalism that is
to say capitalism serves essentially to
allay the same anxieties torments and
disturbances to which the so-called
religions offered answers since the
legalization of marijuana communities of
color black and brown coloradans those
most affected by the racist war on drugs
have now been locked out of the wealth
creation of the industry
[Music]
luckily the public is starting to
understand this unfairness and many
people are now talking of boycotting
cannabis growers who were only white
owned
boycotted away what
we are seeing a healthy and dramatic
spike in consumers who demand that their
marijuana be grown by those who
understand the fight for social equity
aha
the bottom line is this a completely
white owned weed business these days
just isn't going to survive
wow what's he going to do
um okay
let's get back to that fun word we
talked about before
neo-liberalism now it's a slippery term
to define only because it's a bit like
explaining water to a fish
except except we're the fish and
neo-liberalism is basically
everything else um it's a political and
economic ideology that slowly wrapped
its tentacles around everything in our
cultural life
academic david harvey uh describes it
like this neoliberalism is in the first
instance a theory of political and
economic practices that proposes that
human well-being can best be advanced by
liberating individual entrepreneurial
freedoms and skills within an
institutional framework characterized by
strong private property rights free
markets and free trade basically
neoliberals argue that we are most
likely to flourish under free market
economic conditions with limited state
control an unrestrained market and
strong individual rights which i don't
know maybe doesn't sound so bad
but harvey also argues that
neoliberalism is a class project which
is carried out by and serves the
interest of a corporate capitalist class
even notably rich catholic daddy pope
francis has referred to what he calls
the dogma of neo-liberal faith to
describe this system it's almost like
it's a system that people can put their
faith into due to the promise of a
better life but at its core
is just serving a small cadre of bros
kind of like
cryptocurrency
and you might be thinking but sir i am
no neoliberal i completely get how this
is a system that serves the interest of
one tiny group at the expense of the
rest of us how dare you lump me in with
it but according to many scholars um
that's the wild thing about
neoliberalism its brilliance is its
ability to affect everything in our
culture not just economic and political
systems in his book neo-liberalism's
demons adam kotsko argues that
neo-liberalism has become a complete way
of life
with a holistic worldview he even goes
so far as to look at neo-liberalism as a
political theology again following marx
and benjamin's lead and this holistic
world view has penetrated the town of
south park this character is explaining
that the very real plight of
marginalized communities under the war
on drugs is being addressed not through
say
widespread exonerations or by broadening
economic and social support systems for
folks who went to jail for doing or
selling weed instead
the racism inherent in america's drug
policies and weed industry can be solved
by spending your money at the right
businesses and boycotting the wrong ones
it's neoliberalism to a t and of course
we go on to see randy try to turn these
systemic injustices into a clever
marketing opportunity for his own weed
brand actions speak louder than words
gang
i guess
i guess i just want you to think about
it
[Music]
wow
dad got woke
this right here makes me think of one of
my favorite lines from soaring
kierkegaard and this comes from a short
essay called the present age he says
this he says a revolutionary age is an
age of action
ours is the age of advertisement and
publicity it works as a description of
the social effects of neoliberalism in
which the economic system can absorb all
types of calls for change in various
social movements without actually
changing the system that creates those
problems i.e neoliberalism will both
poison you
and sell you the antidote and this is
very much what randy is up to here in
which his response to the systemic
racism at the heart of the weed industry
is to get a picture with tolkien's dad
and throw it up on a billboard and and
this isn't south park saying anything
extreme our current president once
argued that seeing interracial couples
and commercials for major brands was
evidence that our country was less
racist rather than you know simply proof
that marketing to interracial couples is
an economically promising prospect for
big corporations for kierkegaard this
comes down to the distinction between
action and and reflection or
doing the right things and thinking the
right things this emphasis on belief
over action uh complements marx and
benjamin's ideas about capitalism
becoming a type of religion in which
believing the right things is more
important than changing the world in any
significant way it's the difference
between action
and advertising randy isn't reflecting
on inequality in the weed industry to
think critically about his complicity in
this system and what actions could
change it he just wants to feel good by
publicly agreeing with the right ideas
like pajama-wearing real estate agents
performing solidarity with the kids
randy's performing anti-racism for his
own economic interests okay um so let's
check this out stan went to the doctor
because he had symptoms of racism and he
wants to see if the doctor can fix him
you really thought a couple of black
people had a child and named him token
why would anyone name a black kid token
you're a piece of
no i was just you were just going along
with the dominant culture of the white
paradigm that's what you were just get
out of my office you make me sick i'm
sorry
i don't know what's wrong with some
people i wonder if anyone else thought
that this kid's name was token huh
anybody
anyone else just assume his name was
token because that's disgusting and you
are the problem
doctor
i thought i told you to get out of my
office because you seriously make me
sick i'm gonna shut my pants right now
doctor please i don't want to be like
this i'll do anything just tell me what
to do well you want to change then i
suggest you start doing a lot of reading
wow the cure for racism is reading um
struggling to grapple with the history
of racism and your complicity in that
history
read books because this way you can both
get access to the right ideas while also
buying more stuff on amazon.com
thanks jeffrey bezos now think back to
that kierkegaard quote i just mentioned
where rather than passion and action an
age of reflection boils down to
advertising and publicity where critical
thought and social justice become
marketing campaigns where burger king
reminds us that black lives matter in
the same essay the kierkegaard says an
age without passion has no values and
everything is transformed into
representational ideas there are certain
remarks and expressions which though
true and reasonable up to a point are
lifeless when a society has no real
values even statements and ideas that
are true and valid end up becoming
pretty empty that about sums up this
season's thesis statement so far and
while kierkegaard predates the
neoliberal revolution this is what many
argue neoliberalism does it takes
statements and ideas that that could be
true
sucks out their political force turns
them into easily marketed slogans and
sells them back to us as a product real
values are replaced by toothless
cultural signifiers one of our fourth
grade students says he's done a lot of
work and has grown as a person and he'd
like to share his journey with you
please welcome stan marsh
what's up guys you know i've done a lot
of reading lately and i'd like to
announce that the school has allowed me
to declare today jrr token appreciation
day something's a little poser with his
little poser glasses
okay um now to be clear
reading books is good we love books
philosophers especially
love books but
there's reason to be skeptical of stan's
journey beyond his obnoxious pair of
poser spectacles now nietzsche said that
the oversaturation of an age with
history seems to be hostile and
dangerous to life because it can lead an
age into a dangerous mood of irony in
regard to itself and subsequently into
the even more dangerous mood of cynicism
a mood through which the forces of life
are paralyzed and at last destroyed now
here it seems like the show is arguing
for something similar now it's pretty
ironic when neo-liberalism turns
movements about fundamentally changing
the world
into excuses to buy books listen to
podcasts or wear cool t-shirts and this
turns from irony into cynicism when
people slowly start to view everything
as just another marketing ploy and just
stop giving a [ __ ] all together in
reading the lord of the rings to
understand his friend talking stan just
ends up making things about himself and
hasn't done anything to make tolkien's
life any better he's performing a new
type of social identity creating a
tolkien holiday at the school is a
cynical ploy it's stan's way of
performing allyship without actually
changing anything fundamental about
their school town or world okay so
enough with um
symbolic pajamas and you know
weed companies doing marketing and books
let's get to
an industry with integrity purpose and
passion
real estate um so this is episode three
let's cut over here
there's a real estate craze taking over
south park and cartman wants to cash in
you ever heard of a real estate agent
butters well not really yeah well
neither did i so i looked it up on a
bunch of those shows and stuff
you don't do anything you just look nice
and hug people and then when someone
buys themselves a house you make money
well well that's a good deal it's more
than a good deal butters it's legal
theft okay um we're not doing a a real
estate agent reacts or anything here but
it's worth noting that under
neoliberalism rates of home ownership
have plummeted and housing is turned
into a commodity with exponentially
rising values values that sometimes seem
disconnected from the reality of housing
is a thing that humans need in the past
year or so there have been multiple
stories about how more and more
single-family homes are being purchased
by wall street investment firms or
silicon valley investors these groups
grabbed 15 of available homes in the
first quarter of 2021 that's not
counting all the homes purchased to be
turned into airbnbs and other short-term
rental investments carmen sees that
something about the system smells like
bull but more than both he smells an
opportunity to exploit the bull
for cash i can almost hear the crowds
chanting usa usa right now because
creating an industry around what should
be a human right and then making wild
profits of speculating on that thing is
very much in neoliberalism's q zone it
doesn't work that way eric you aren't
going to make any money you're just
driving up the market and none of your
deals will make it through escrow well
we'll just see in 30 days won't we
except for some of my deals which have a
45-day contingency period okay that
can't be real because all the real
estate shows on tv tell me that um you
make lots of money and it's super easy
um real estate agents hit us in the
comments and let us know now cartman is
operating under the conditions of
neo-liberal reality the one that sells
us on the idea that home ownership is
the most important thing we can do with
our money the one that pumps out more
real estate reality shows and we have
time to watch and the one that tries to
convince us that a housing crisis caused
by unaffordable housing can be solved by
building more housing
for real estate agents to sell and for
wall street firms to buy now carbon's
mom is aware that much of the system is
just a house of cards waiting to fall
down but she's still complicit within it
and we can understand this via french
psychoanalyst jacques lacan who is very
familiar with folks like kierkegaard
petra and marx that we've discussed so
far he's also the obi-wan kenobi to slav
voice gex luke skywalker now lecon drew
a distinction between reality which is
the product of all the symbols and
structures that make up our social world
and the real
which is all the messy stuff that exists
on the other side of those symbols and
structures and is in constant tension
with reality in other words the real is
what any reality has to suppress and
reality is constituted via this act of
repression it's a mind of a concept and
lacan himself changed its meaning
throughout his life but the point here
is that neoliberalism a system pretty
accurately represented in these episodes
creates a reality that tries to cover up
the real and in this season at least so
far trey and matt are pushing some of
the holy grails of neoliberalism to the
point where we can see the absurdity of
this reality and while the show isn't
offering any magical solutions to the
neoliberal condition david harvey has
said that resistance to neoliberalism
can occur in a number of different ways
in my work i stress that the point at
which value is realized is also a point
of tension value is produced in the
labor process and this is a very
important aspect of class struggle but
value is realized in the market through
sale and there's a lot of politics to
that a lot of resistance to capital
accumulation occurs not only on the
point of production but also through
consumption and the realization of value
so basically one way of resistance is at
the point at which we make stuff i.e
work but there is also an opportunity
for resistance in consumption meaning
that we have the ability to call
[ __ ] on some of the products and
ideas that neoliberalism sells to us as
valuable and important okay guys i i
know i threw kind of a lot of you today
but what else do you expect when they
set me loose on 60 minutes of adult
animation with a stack of books and a
fresh bag of coffee beans and if this
all seems complicated
it's because neo-liberalism is
incredibly complex and requires all the
tools of philosophy theology economics
and even psychoanalysis to really
understand the system and what the
system is doing to us and because matt
and trey are cranky gen x libertarians
and not a couple of wine soaked french
marxists they offer no underlying
message for how the world should be in
these episodes and that's okay because
these episodes still make it possible to
look at some philosophical ideas that
run right through the 19th 20th and 21st
centuries and if you want to dig deeper
i will leave you a reading list in the
description so check those out now
thanks again for hanging out with us and
please jump in the comments and let us
know what you think about the ideas
being explored in this season of south
park a huge thanks as always to our
patrons for supporting our channel and
be sure to check out wisecrack's podcast
as well hit that subscribe button like
you're ringing a massive bell that lets
the world know that you think all the
right things and don't forget to ring
that actual bell either as always let us
know if there's any other content that
you think warrants a philosophical
once-over as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
i would never have pre-marital sex
during lent
or uh
or or on christmas
because because it's just it's just a
hot day you're under the mistletoe
you've had a few egg dogs mom and dad
are asleep you go you know it's it's a
good day for that